all right let's get into the mailbag for
the week the mailbag continues to be
increasingly popular both for people who
have something constructive and
substantive to share
and people who have nothing of value to
share other than insults slurs and the
like you can email info davidpakman.com
if you have a message for us that maybe
would be interesting to discuss during
the mailbag
let's start today
with the email
you're a bully
paid for by george soros and alex soros
now i have to admit i have never heard
the name alex soros before um suggesting
that um
shows hosted by jewish people
are paid for by jewish person george
soros is
a very well established anti-semitic
trope um we have been targeted by it for
a very long time
uh i i have never been accused of being
paid by alex soros and i don't know who
that is presumably the son of george
soros i don't know
sounds interesting i wonder what he's up
to and of course you're a bully
who am i bullying would be the question
i have that is not uh also not an
allegation
i have ever faced uh lance wrote in
asking about our facebook situation
saying david i watched your show about a
week ago where you talked about facebook
demonetizing your content for 90 days
over essentially reporting the news this
got my ire up and i contacted a friend
that works for facebook who looked into
it further
here is the official reply thank you for
bringing this to our attention we've
reviewed the content you reported and
found it doesn't violate community
standards we apologize for the mistake
here and have restored your content and
taken steps to ensure it doesn't happen
again um and lance wants to know what
happened yes
i am now able to announce that thanks to
you about 10 of you actually we have a
ton of facebook employees in our
audience it turns out or friends and
family of facebook employees thanks to
uh all of you guys
we have been re-monetized re-monetized
on facebook a bunch of people wrote in
saying
this is not anti-vaccine content the
david pakman show is not anti-vaxx
this is some kind of false algorithmic
thing
and we learned that indeed no real
person
flagged our account
something about our post
could have been the the thumbnail which
included alex jones could have been the
text we don't know got us demonetized
and it was incorrect and so a whole
bunch of you guys who work at facebook
submitted internal appeals it took about
15 days or so
16 days something like that but we are
remonetized on facebook and i have only
you guys to thank so i really appreciate
that let's continue with the mailbag
mike wrote in
and is not pleased with me mike says
david i noticed that on the january 19th
show you mentioned how to get at home
coveted tests would be in the bonus show
i'm sure you didn't intend this but
putting that content behind a paywall
could be viewed as tacky or underhanded
way of encouraging subscriptions the
information is not secret it's it's why
it's just covatest.gov
every day this one is frustrating every
day i just tell people what's on the
bonus show and so that day it was like
we're going to talk about the new
program to get free covet tests we're
going to talk about this we're going to
talk about that
you can just google free kova tests it's
the first thing that comes up
the information is not secret in any way
i was not encouraging subscriptions with
the idea that i would tell you where to
get free coveted tests if you get a
membership
um
a little frustrating because i mean it's
a biden plan it was all over the news
it's kobates.gov
but okay it is what it is
bill wrote in about the january 6th
committee
and says hi david sir
is there there is one thing that i would
that would greatly impact voters and
voting in 2022 or 2024.
if the committee shows somehow
that trump had nothing to do with what
happened on january 6th i know it's
unlikely
but stranger things have happened think
2016. that's a really good point so what
it what is this about
last week
i said
i want the january 6 committee to finish
its work before the november elections
why
if republicans win in november
as soon as they're sworn in in january
they're ending the committee
so i would like the committee to
actually finish its work
without being forcibly shut down even
though i know that no matter what the
committee says the committee could say
trump was the one guy who planned the
insurrection or whatever and it would
not change the minds of voters in other
words i don't think the results of that
committee will make a difference
bill has a good point
which is if the results were trump is
completely innocent and has no blame
whatsoever no one around trump has any
blame for the insurrection
that actually might impact 2024 and it
would be similar sort of to that last
minute james comey press conference
remember for all the talk of james comey
being so uh um hostile to trump and
friendly to hillary james comey choosing
to do that second press conference about
the hillary email investigation so close
to the 2016 election
absolutely played a role to some degree
we can't say it was a decisive role but
it played a role in the ultimate outcome
so i don't think that's going to happen
bill i agree with you but if it did if
the if the results were we finished our
investigation and trump did nothing
wrong and neither did anybody around him
that actually would be a factor i don't
expect that that's going to happen
uh haley wrote in about carhartt this i
like this story
uh conservatives on carhartt's news
revealing their vaccine mandate are big
mad and making my night we definitely
should be supporting their business just
the most recent facebook post on their
page has the right acting like
snowflakes i love the story so
a lot of people i i think don't know
about the brand carhart now i'm going to
try to accurately describe it carhartt
is a brand that sells a lot of sort of
like working gear particularly for the
cold or at least growing up in
massachusetts i would always see people
on construction site would have carhartt
pants
fleece-lined carhartt jackets and there
was this association with carhartt as
being a conservative brand rightly or
wrongly
and it may have been because it became
popular
with um
sort of
folks who um
see it as
uh emblematic of rugged individualism
and being out doing
work uh you know
chainsaws and whatever anyway you guys
get the point and growing up
there was always like nearby i went to
like the
[Music]
regular high school and there was an
alternative vocational high school and
the vocational high school was
significantly more conservative in its
makeup and there were a lot of carhartt
stuff around so i think there's the
association of carhartt as a
conservative brand that may not even be
accurate turns out carhartt requires
their employees to be vaccinated and it
has gone crazy with conservatives saying
we will now boycott carhartt i saw
videos of people burning carhartt
clothes and all of this different stuff
i absolutely love it
um i don't know if there is an
alternative to carhartt is ll bean
really an alternative i don't doesn't
seem like i don't know i don't know much
about carhartt as a brand
but uh i am loving the instant
triggering that we are seeing from these
people because their beloved carhartt
says hey for safety you got to be
vaccinated to work here dustin wrote in
dustin says could or would ron desantis
pardon
donald trump if trump goes to prison and
desantis becomes president could
desantis pardon trump to earn the
political favor of trump supporters and
would he so there's two issues here and
one of the issues is timing and let me
explain what i mean by that
desantis would want the
support of trumpists
to become president if he runs meaning
he needs the support before being
president he could only pardon trump
once he is president so now of course he
could announce while running if you vote
for me
i will pardon trump if trump were to be
convicted of some crimes which i don't i
don't think is going to happen so it
would be a campaign promise desantis
could make he couldn't actually do it
until he were president
but i actually see
that the growing rift between trump and
desantis will keep growing trump has
been attacking desantis of late desantis
has come back and fired at trump a
little bit and saying shouldn't have
followed him so much early in the
pandemic so i i think that
the hostilities between trump and
desantis are much much more likely to
continue growing rather than the
possibility that uh desantis says i will
save the hero trump elect me to keep him
safe i just don't see it
we don't know if trump's running in 24
we don't know if desantis is running in
24 but that's my sense on a desantis
trump pardon could he pardon him yes
would he really do it i don't know that
it really helps his strategy
amanda wrote in and amanda said hey
david i see in your videos that you've
needed to mention when information on a
video you're showing your audience are
lies and have been debunked i've noticed
you would need to pause the video after
each lie to let us in your audience know
it isn't true and to remain in
compliance with youtube would having a
disclaimer on the bottom of the screen
be sufficient enough at the start
mentioning the content we're about to
watch is information that has been
debunked and is not true play the video
stop for your normal commentary message
on the bottom says this isn't true or
something like that
i don't know i've noticed times taken
away to stay in compliance was wondering
if there's any way around that yeah i
don't think so you know my understanding
that we've gotten from youtube is you
need to actually the content needs to be
when there is a misstatement you have to
point out that it's a misstatement and i
know it gets a little clunky and we're
thinking about ways around it remember
we're also on some platforms that are
audio only so having something visually
on the bottom of the screen that says
these are lies you were listening to
wouldn't really help but i appreciate
the the sentiment and uh we're going to
keep working on it amanda
cami wrote in and says do democrats want
to lose
david sir i've been thinking about this
for a while now but due to them do the
democrats want to lose elections i know
the idea seems crazy but when i think
about the people who were helped by the
republican tax cuts most of the house
and senate members on both sides of the
aisle would be at the income level to
profit off of what was done
i do believe that on social issues
democrats do have strong feelings but it
seems like they are still rich people
with a lot to gain from republican
policy do they want to profit while also
being able to cast no votes they know in
the end won't matter because they're in
the minority crazy thought but maybe
there's some truth in there so there's
two things here cami you're right
that on some issues
democrats
in power seem to have the same interest
as republicans but they don't hide that
we know that there's lots of issues
where you actually just ask them their
opinion
and there's very little difference
between democrats and republicans and
we've talked about actual interest in
enforcing antitrust right i mean we
there's a bunch of different issues at
the end of the day
democrats want
democrats benefit from being in power
and the prestige that comes with it
more than saving a couple of points off
of their taxes if the top tax rate is 37
instead of 39 so while you're
mathematically correct
that many democrats
in power in the house and senate pay
slightly lower taxes thanks to the trump
tax cuts i don't think that those two
points are enough to make them say we
don't even want to be in power
uh to save those two percentage points i
think they have much more to gain by
being in positions of power that's my
instinct and of course you know you you
might disagree but that's uh all the
evidence i've seen points in that
direction
all right if you have something you want
to ask me talk to me about
inquire about criticize demand a
correction for even
you can email info davidpakman.com
and maybe your email will be featured on
next week's mailbag remember that the
show doesn't have to end now we do the
bonus show every day for our members and
you can sign up at joinpacman.com